هذه السحليه البرمائيه الهمه العلماء على
اختراع تقنيه ثوريه في تخزين الكهرباء
باحثون من جامعه صينيه طور بالتعاون مع
جامعه بريطانيه مكثفات فائقه التخزين
للكهرباء تحتفظ بالطاقه من خلال ابتكار
قطب كهربائي يتنفس غاز الكلوريد وهي طريقه
مشابهه للسحالي التي تتنفس تحت الماء
بفقاعه هوائيه مرتبطه براسها المكثفات
تساعد السيارات والحافلات على توفير
الطاقه بفضل توليدها لشحنه كهربائيه
مرتفعه خلال وقت قصير فالعلماء يبحثون عن
طريقه جديده لجمع ميزات البطاريات
والمكثفات معا في تلك المكثفات الفائقه
دون رفع تكلفه انتاجها وهو ما يفسح المجال
الاحتمال ظهور جيل جديد من البطن بالاضافه
الى تطوير عمليات الشحن السريع والبطاريه
طويله الامل
[موسيقى]